[Music]
we're eternals
we came here to protect humans from the
deviants
when you love something
you fight for it
dad i saw him on tv with the cape
shooting laser beams
i don't wear a cape
you can't protect
any of them
let's finish this
marvel studios eternal sweetie pg-13
only in theaters november 5th
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
[Applause]
how long do we have
seven days
[Music]
we're eternals
we came here seven thousand years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
[Music]
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're
[Music]
sarcasm we have loved these people since
the day we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
you